when I first became aware that Donald
Trump was actually running for president
my thought was this can't possibly be
happening basically for 25 years Donald
Trump had been flirting with the idea of
running for president was basically a
way for him to get a bunch of attention
a combination of clearly undisciplined
candidate like Donald Trump and and a
handful of very competent Republicans or
seemingly competent Republicans
suggested a repeat of this cycle we saw
in 2012 you know a lot of news outlets
had already put their best reporters on
Jeb Bush he was supposed to be the
front-runner at the sort of presumed
Republican nominee and
you know you're out I guess I didn't
really take it as seriously as I could
have or should have it's hard to
actually think that this person who's a
showman is going to launch this credible
campaign for president
yeah
so early 2014 I arranged to interview
Donald Trump on his plane so I
inadvertently spent two days with Trump
down at his kind of beachside compound
in Palm Beach interviewing him getting
to know him the piece that I wrote kind
of called him out for 25 years of
pretending to run for president just to
kind of get attention I predicted quite
confidently that he never would actually
run for president yes so when Trump
announced he was running for president
he came down with his wife on this
escalator in Trump Tower coming down the
escalator I think the few of us will
forget that image but the escalator
everything I think the mood was sort of
jolly about it I mean I think and I
think that goes for a lot of newsrooms I
was actually up in New Hampshire
covering a Jeb Bush campaign rally and I
remember just sitting in this like Town
Hall in New Hampshire like watching the
tweets come in about Trump's
announcement and I remember I think I
tweeted something like I feel like I'm
being Punk'd
when I first saw a Trump event in a
person I think that's when it all sort
of came together it was just a kind of a
political event I'd never seen before
when I was in a cab ride back to my
hotel and I was on the phone with my
editor kind of giving my readout of what
had happened and kind of talking about
insider political analysis and I
remember all of a sudden the the cab
driver just like was obviously
eavesdropping on me the cab driver
barked something like Trump is winning
because he understands real Americans
were just getting out of a cab and
they're like okay this is probably
happening when he went after John McCain
for having been captured as a prisoner
of war and there was all this
condemnation that came from the
Republican Party for him to be able to
say what he said which was actually in
many ways cruises involved prisoners of
war and to not have it affect his
support whatsoever that was that moment
where I thought this isn't just your
average trinidade I would say that my
own feeling about this really turned
around the time of the Paris attacks and
Trump's ability to capitalize the Paris
attacks and kind of open up a new front
policy front which is the ban on Muslims
in the United States his votes share
like went up so I kind of had two
conclusions first the Republican base is
really eating whatever Trump is cooking
with regards to bigotry and nativism and
second I don't think the Republican
Party institutionally is equipped to
deal with it and if it's not equipped to
deal with it then I'm not sure how
they're going to stop it
the thing that I realized is that I
underestimated Trump because I thought
that all he wanted was attention and
what I think he really wanted was
respect and that's much more deeply
rooted than I ever realized it goes all
the way back to when he was kind of this
outer-borough kid in Queens who wanted
to live in Manhattan and be accepted as
a true Manhattan elite and he's kind of
had this outsider status anxiety his
entire life and I think that I didn't
realize how deeply he felt that and how
that would fuel him to do something so
kind of outlandish is actually run for
president